time I think this is 12 a pot one okay
now if you're doing the reciprocal okay
you want to think about the important
features and then you connect the dots
okay think about the important features
and then connect the dots so the first
most important para features actually is
that B this is a reciprocal where the
original function is zero what does that
mean for the reciprocal function you'll
get asymptotes weren't you so that's um
I'll do it in this car so there's your
first vertical asymptote at going
through the origin and your second one
which is going through x equals two okay
so I should put that on okay now you
look at some other useful features here
right you have a stationary point and
you know exactly where the stationary
point is now we were pretty sloppy and
I'm translating that on to your brand
it's at one - so what's the reciprocal
of to moderate I remember it's a hub
isn't it
Wow the variety of places where you put
this new stationary point sometimes it
was close to a half sometimes it was
nowhere near it very few people actually
labeled it if they label you should
label okay make sense
so there's the first thing we put on
there at one
aha if it's not your question that's
fine but it'll be for some of you that's
why I'm clicking it out right now what
happens since we started on this inside
section what happens to the left and
right of the stationary point okay well
if you're approaching zero for both of
these right that's the denominator
approaches zero what's happening to the
reciprocal function if it's denominator
is approaching zero what's happening to
the whole thing it's going to skyrocket
isn't it so do this
okay so apart from the choppy position
of this nation repoint like some of you
even put your stationary point up here
at the original way the original
stationary point was because you didn't
realize that that was a - you're gonna
be careful okay now let's have a look at
the left in the right over the left here
okay we're approaching an asymptote
aren't we
now what asking to it are we approaching
it's a they give a sequential right this
is my scales really off actually
sorry about that it should be minus one
so that should be much lower down but
I'm running out of space okay now if
you're approaching negative one what's
the reciprocal of negative one
it's negative as well right so when
you're taking the reciprocal function
and you take the limit as X approaches
negative infinity that's where you're
going why am i below the axis the whole
time how can I do it like why don't how
do I know it's not approaching from the
top when you have a look at what you're
taking the reciprocal off all of these
guys are negative right so all of their
reciprocals will also be negative all
right lost pace some of you saw all I
have an asymptote over here so that's
why I'm approaching and you drew it
approaching the same as sometime over
here but it's not and you need to think
carefully because it's not a symmetrical
graph so in some senses we should expect
it to do the both in the same thing on
both sides over here it's dropping like
a rock to negative infinity so what's
its reciprocal doing what's it
approaching it's zero right so that's
why if moisture and you have to draw in
a new asymptote right
okay that's what that looks like but two
marks I was looking for this section up
here this parabola will be part being
corrected at having the location of a
stationary point right and the second
mark was for both of these branches
underneath the axis you need is now both
of them if one of them was wrong then
you lost that mark even if the other
side was correct now let's have a look
at this one there were two marks come on
you're pretty smart where do you think
the two marks went think about it shape
is a good thing to judge but I'm kind of
judging shape all the way through right
what's the difference between this and
the original graph there are two
differences out there what are the two
differences there's a shift and a
stretch a scale issue so this is
vertical and this is horizontal so I was
looking for each okay and a lot of
people will do one but not the other
super instance if I moved over right the
roots are not going to be 0 2 anymore
what will they be instead of 0 and shoot
they'll both be shifted one unit to the
left so I'll be at 1 and negative 1 okay
you're going to get the same kind of
shape happening but that's not the only
change since it's vertically different
right my max used to be a 2 what will my
max be right now
it'll be a 4 so up your scale goes right
Oh what have you forgot to put that up
there right the max used to be at 1 but
I'm shifted want you to over to the left
so where should the max be now right on
the axis right there
okay the last important piece to the
scale is that see how you've got your
horizontal asymptote here at negative 1
well that's going to go down just like
this going up okay so negative 2
so that's what I'm going to press there
you got all your pieces and you can draw
the field let's let's give a guy that's
doing that this is gonna come down I
missed but you get the idea and I'm
approaching this new asset oh okay yeah